hey guys I'm Eric box and this is a full
breakdown of all the Easter eggs
references and general interesting
details that you might have missed in
Sherlock series for episode 1 the sixth
factor and if you're new to this channel
we here at new rock stars like Zig deep
and to visuals and dialogue and hidden
details and meaning basically doing are
not as good version of what Sherlock
does to pretty much everyone he meets
now I've always down to talk about
Sherlock and all the great links to the
characters history and I know we're a
little behind on this episode but this
is Sherlock and it's always fun to go
back and find stuff that you missed the
first time around so what the hell let's
do this okay it's old so this episode
opens with a prologue scene that neatly
ties up things from the end of series 3
his last vow and last year's special
episode the abominable bride but aside
from clearing Sherlock from executing
Magnussen this scene also sets up some
crucial information for starters notice
how the first character that we get a
goal clear shot of and who's a seemingly
periphery character that the script
makes a point of telling us her name
which woman Vivian Vivian Norbury so
this episode nicholae reveals the
villain in the opening moment so that
and through mystery fashion she was
under our noses the whole time you
remember the show pulled the same exact
move with Moriarty back in series 1 also
of course Mycroft mentioned all the code
names for people who have access to this
classified Intel code names Antarctica
banging Dale Pollock and love obviously
love becomes a clue later in the episode
but these code names are also references
themself Langdale pike is name of
Sherlock society gossip source from the
adventure of the three gables and
someone who shows up in a lot of other
Sherlock spin-off and Porlock is the
Moriarty associate who gives Sherlock a
tip in the valley of fear okay moving on
past these new series for opening
credits to this opening narration of the
appointment in Samarra story which
becomes an extended metaphor for this
episode there was once an merchant the
famous market of that guy
the theme is that it's impossible to
escape our past choices and our attempts
to flee them always lead us directly
back to dealing with the consequences of
those choices and I'll talk about how
this relates to Sherlock and the other
character is a little later it's also
interesting that when you look into the
history of the appointment in Samarra
which itself is a reference to W
Somerset mom's retelling of an
mesopotamian tail and in that version
death takes the form of a woman so even
though Sherlock doesn't really underline
this it's a key foreshadowing of the
form that death takes this episode and
the life that death takes the opening
and narration also establishes an
important visual language for the six
Thatcher's with the aquarium that's
embodied in the shark and the blue light
refracting through the water which
returns to haunt Sherlock and foreshadow
the location where death awaits them a
final destination if you will this
episode tomorrow the London Aquarium
real quick notice this image of what
looks like a whale skeleton so not only
is aquatic imagery linked with death in
a general sense whales are used as a
recurring symbol for the person who dies
this episode which I'm about to spoil
but why are you watching this video if
you haven't seen the episode yet Mary
Watson but Mary isn't the only character
who's linked with an animal because when
we move on back to Sherlock back on
Baker Street even as this about Moriarty
I'm good to MoMA to the underworld every
quiver of the web becoming in this
presentation so Sherlock has famously
compared Moriarty to a spider both in
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's the final
problem where he says he sits motionless
like a spider in the center of its web
but that web has a thousand radiation
and he knows every quiver of each of
them and then of course the adaptation
of that quote in the show in the right
Ken Vauxhall jamesemorrow using the
marital Jesus spider
Spyder the central web criminal web with
a thousandth resident has precisely how
each and every single one of them dances
and then we get this montage of Sherlock
solving crimes on Twitter it looks like
which is a fitting update to the
character now that we live in a time
when governing is happening on Twitter
apparently and naturally there are a few
winks here with the wrong thumb possibly
referencing the adventure of the
engineers some and the fact that
Sherlock has kept severed thumbs in his
fridge in the past there's also a
Sherlock telling John it's another twist
which is a callback to the abominable
bride episode because it's never twins
the circus torso could be a nod to the
adventure of the veiled lodger which
features a story where a circus
performer gets disfigured by a lion and
then the canary trainer of course is one
of Holmes's lost cases and Arthur Conan
Doyle stories and other authors have
adapted this name as well also notice
now right before John and Sherlock rush
off Mary who's going into labor they're
joking them out you gotta mess with
Jenny Trish now this is a real subtle
foreshadowing of the final act in the
aquarium where Sherlock has seen flanked
by jellyfish so once again when
characters try to outrun their past and
move on with their lives with like a new
baby the specter of death represented by
aquatic imagery looms over them another
moment that hints at this is when mrs.
Hudson tries to take a family photo of
it but the picture won't come out
similar to how this kind of
foreshadowing device was used in the
movie the ring this moment is implying
that the Watsons will never embody the
image of a happy family now if sherlock
solves even more cases we get even more
winks with fresh paint to disguise
another smell even a reference to the
adventure of the retired color man where
a man paints his house to cover up the
smell of gas that he used to kill his
life in her lover also the random line
if dog can't swim neighbor is the killer
seems very similar to Sherlock's text in
the pilot episode this brother has green
ladder arrest brother and then at the
baptism Sherlock positives when he
learns the baby's name Rosamund Mary
obviously cements the reveal of Mary's
true name Rosamund Mary Rosamund
Rosamund Mary and this brings me to my
favorite moment of the episode the twist
of Sherlock delivering his classic see
with the nose observe to you the world
remains an impenetrable mystery whereas
the mute is an open book hard logic
versus romantic whimsy that is your
choice you fail to connect actions to
their consequences then the reveal that
is talking to the next generation of
Watson Rosie do not throw the Black Rock
then check this out what are those
animals and Rosie's mobile those are
black whales
now of course newborns can't see color
yet so you often see black and white
baby stuff but I still think that these
are another example of Mary Watson's
association with whales and death and no
I don't think the show is making a yo
mama joke here but whales are
surprisingly some of the smartest
mammals on earth and research shows that
their emotional intelligence might
surpass human and like Mary whales
lifespan significantly reduced when
they're kept in captivity even if they
try to replicate the semblance of the
natural habitat so yeah connecting Mary
to whales kind of makes a lot of sense
but let's move on to the Wellsboro house
where if you just watch this show for
Sherlock using his deduction powers to
solve mysteries this short kind of sad
subplot with a son suffering a seizure
hidden underneath the fake car seat is
really all you're going to get this
episode because pretty quickly this
story makes an abrupt right turn where
this episode gets its title the sixth
statures now the sixth sacher's is based
on the short story the adventure of the
sixth Napoleon and that story a criminal
tracks down and smashes a series of
plaster busts of napoleon bonaparte
because as Holmes reveals the man hid
the black pearl of the Borgias inside
one of them and that's why in the first
half of this episode we get a bunch of
mentions of the stolen black pearl of
the Borgias okay said Sherlock initially
find boring until the point that he
believes that it's connected with the
Batchelor busts and perhaps Moriarty we
also get a little link to Napoleon with
Sherlock PACCAR friend Craig Perry and
Margaret Thatcher to a historical figure
like Napoleon Tom's a great leader in it
Sasha join our Napoleon now let's go
back to this moment when Sherlock Earths
notices the missing bus the aquatic
imagery returns in Sherlock says this
line by the pricking constellation
that's actually a reference to a couple
things first the witches and
Shakespeare's make that and say by the
pricking of my thumb's Something Wicked
This Way Comes it's an expression that
means and then to ative sense of
foreboding and doom and even though
Sherlock can't really place it he can
feel that this bust is connected to
death which waits for him in his
underwater Samarra and also fun fact by
the pricking of my thumb's is the name
of a mystery novel by Agatha Christie
and before I move on I love the
callbacks to the recurring gags of
Sherlock not knowing basic information
like the fact that Margaret Thatcher was
a famous British prime minister if you
remember he also didn't know who the
Prime
mr. was back in series 1 also this scene
ends with Sherlock taking off alone and
leaving John behind in some remote place
which is something he tends to do to
John a lot let's move on to the scene
when Sherlock is talking with his
brother Mycroft Sherlock's obsession
with the spidery Moriarty combines with
the Aquatic imagery and the appointment
tomorrow metaphor in this line though it
is which is live at the Strand crossing
every other we hope premonition has just
moved into the web so for Sherlock this
is all connected it's gut instinct that
death waits for him under the scene and
his frustration that unlike Moriarty he
can't interpret or control the vast web
of faith that connects everything that's
why it's important that Mycroft reminds
him that as a boy
Sherlock wrote his own version of the
tale an appointment in Sumatra where the
merchant is able to avoid death
altogether so for Sherlock it is and
always has been crucial for him to feel
in control of his own destiny also I
love the callback with Mycroft st. and
it becomes a pirate now we've seen
throughout the show that Sherlock was
obsessed with pirates as a kid but
initially he wanted to be a pirate and
this pirate stuff actually comes back
later but moving on to Sherlock's
exchange with the carpenter include this
line salute you've done something clever
you've explained it simple in it that's
listed directly from the adventure of
the red-headed league also you may have
noticed that it's ironic that Sherlock
tells Lestrade to take the credit for
the sixth a true case even though
Lestrade knows that John will blog about
it anyway and the credit will go to
Sherlock this is a nod to the more
arrogant version of Lestrade and short
stories who always demand credit for
solving each case even though he didn't
really do it and the publishing of the
short stories will end up undercutting
his pride anyway and then Sherlock
enlist the help of Craig the hacker and
his dog Toby which is the name of
Sherlock's dog and a few of the short
stories but that Toby was very different
from this one like he wasn't a
bloodhound and he was extremely helpful
in tracking things down whereas this
bloodhound
according to Steven Moffat and Mark
Gatiss was completely unmovable and this
little scene with a dog Oshin list says
like Mary straddles them this was added
after they realized how much of a diva
this dog was going to be now noticed a
scene with John and Mary talking about
their crying baby like she's the
possessed girl from The Exorcist or the
Antichrist boy from The Omen now it
might be a stretch but I feel like this
could be a subtle foreshadowing of the
later reveal of Mary's name Rosamund
because the Exorcist in The Omen
and are often grouped together with a
third film about demonic kids Rosemary's
Baby so I feel like the next reference
Mary was going to make is that this baby
is crying so hard she's like Rosamund
mary's baby right it seems like it could
be more than a coincidence maybe I'm
just reading anything okay then later on
when Sherlock finds the final bust and
AJ who's Mary's mercenary ex-colleague
notice how the show places this fight in
the pool so this is a visual trick a
fake-out the whole episode up until this
point has led us to believe that
Sherlock's will meet his doom in the
water but we know it's not going to
happen here right like we still have 50
minutes of this episode left and this
guy is kind of a nobody but what it does
tell us is that the whole mystery of the
Black Pearl is like many Sherlock
mysteries a total red herring this is
not Sherlock's final act or the
underwater Samara that he's been
dreading this ocean goes way deeper in
Sherlock's excitement over solving this
mystery is just really misplaced so the
second half of this episode focuses on
the real story here Mary's ghosts of the
past coming back to haunt her and even
though some of you may have caught this
when his last vow came out the very
decision to make the acronym on the
memory stick agri is in itself a
reference to Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's
novel the sign of for remember that was
an inspiration for the title of the
series 3 episode the sign of three that
was the wedding episode this book
introduced Mary as a character she's a
woman who's seeking the Agra treasure
which involves a map signed by four
people the sign of four it was a pact to
never betray each other
similarly this Agra memory stick has a
sign of four pact between these four
mercenaries and here Mary called
Sherlock a Dragonslayer
which is another callback to his last
valve where Sherlock wanted to go after
Magnussen for blackmailing Mary to honor
his vow to protect her John and their
child and in my crops compared Sherlock
to Christmas Lana
but speaking of Magnussen while Sherlock
is knocked out he sees a flashback of
himself as a child where you can see
Sherlock wearing a pirate hat as well as
a family dog red beard which is named
after the famous pirate and that memory
of red beard was apparently one of
Sherlock's pressure points that
Magnussen kept in his mind and I have a
feeling that this memory and
specifically the dog red beard is going
to be important later to series okay
moving on Mary's randomized journey
around the world could be a callback to
Molly's line during a baptism that the
name Rosamund
translates to
and today this Easter egg the name on
the passport is Gabrielle Ashdown that's
the reference to the 1970 movie the
private life of Sherlock Holmes where
Sherlock and a Belgian woman named
Gabrielle used the alias of Ashdown
while travelling gabrielle ash found and
actually that movie contains an
interesting exchange between Sherlock
and Gabrielle about whether or not women
can be trusted so this comes right after
Sherlock learned that Mary can't be
trusted now let's talk about John he's
having an affair with e the woman he met
on the bus now some people pointed out
how the text chimes that we hear when
John taxi in the kitchen versus when he
texts her later that night they sound a
little different and that might mean
that he could be texting someone else
knotti later on now obviously next
episode kind of debunked that theory but
I think it's designed to make us do a
double-take on e as a story arc also if
you look closely the background of the
bus stop there are some interesting
clues
so first behind John you can see a sign
that says killer whale that's one final
whale image that shows up right as John
seemed to flirt with a stranger implying
that he's about to lose his wife also
behind e later there's a poster showing
culverton Smith that's the villain who's
introduced in episode 2 the line
detective even I up for my video on that
but for now let's move on to this final
confrontation in the London Aquarium
after Sherlock is able to deduce that a
mole of wasn't used by Smallwood but
rather her secretary someone who as Mary
putted Sherlock says this line which is
a common expression in the short story
and naturally Vivian or brewery echos
the appointment in Samarra tale
revealing that like Sherlock and Mary
she spent her life looking over her
shoulder expecting to find that death
had finally caught up to her and notice
who says the word death here so by this
point this episode has made it very
clear what's about to happen also in
case we didn't catch this I love the
subtle callback that Norbury makes here
why did you betray us
London anyone do anything if you
remember back in the series one finale
the great game
Moriarty spoke the same line to Sherlock
through the hostage
why does anyone
to me that seems to imply that Vivian
Norbury might have been an associate
client or pawn of some kind to Moriarty
so the death of Mary Watson is the
appointment in Samarra that all these
characters have tried to avoid but walk
into nonetheless Vivian or Barry it
turns out is the mo that betrayed Marion
publicity and ended her life as a
mercenary a life that Mary was trying to
escape just to come face-to-face with
and that same betrayal ended the life
set Norbury wanted to leave behind -
before Sherlock forced her to answer for
it and for Sherlock Mary's death is hits
tomorrow - because it means the death of
his Val as well as a fatal blow to his
friendship with John this moment was
Sherlock and the therapist is meant to
parallel the therapists scene with John
and the Reichenbach Fall in both cases
it's one friend trying to process the
loss of the others moving on this team
with Mycroft has a few interesting
details that I should mention first off
I like how the fridge is empty which
seems like a callback to how overweight
Mycroft was in the abominable bride but
also there's a menu for a place called
the right gate square which is a
reference to the right date Squire short
story and then of course Mycroft is
calling someone named Sharon Ford and
there's a bunch of theories about the
history of that name and who that person
is but the next episode does reveal who
that is so I'll talk about that in the
other video and finally let's talk about
this final scene back on Baker Street
Sherlock tells miss Hudson that work is
the best antidote - Starro which is
exactly what Sherlock says about John's
bereavement and the adventure of the
empty house but then notice when
Sherlock says this line you ever think
I'm becoming a bit full of myself cocky
or overconfident you could you just say
the word
noir Bree to me this is almost a direct
quote from the adventure of the yellow
face where Sherlock is talking about
another Norbury a borough in South West
London where Sherlock makes a critical
error and he suggests the name Norbury
as a way to remind him of his ride
blinding himself which he definitely
needs because it was Sherlock's
aggressive taunting of Vivienne or Barry
an armed woman with nothing to lose that
led directly to Mary's death so then
Sherlock receives the Miss Nude DVD but
instead of another post-mortem video
from Moriarty it's a post mortem video
for Mary and her words are a direct
callback to the empty hearse last season
when she and Sherlock had a similar
exchange over
mutual affection for John now after the
credit there is a quick shot of Mary
that a lot of people are talking about
go to hell shock now that could read as
a joke but the way Mary says it it
seemed kind of serious so what does she
mean now there was a popular theory that
said Mary could have been referring to
Hell Norway which is a really small town
in Norway and might have been a place
that Mary visited during her Worldport
and considering that this show does have
a history of bringing people back from
the dead maybe Mary could be waiting for
Sherlock there and definitely if you
watch next episode characters coming
back and different forms is never
something to rule out we will see okay
thanks for watching and let me know what
you think in the comments and keep an
eye out for my breakdown of the next
episode the line detective and please
hit like and subscribe to new rockstars
and share this video with all your
friends you can also contribute to new
rockstars on patreon so thanks so much
all of our current donors if you aren't
currently a patron we would love your
support you can hit me up on twitter at
EI vos with any thoughts through
theories that you have about Sherlock
you can also follow a new rock stars on
Twitter at new rock stars alright thanks
for watching bye
[Music]